[APPLAUSE]
GREG PROOPS: Thank you, brother.
Hi, you guys.
Thank you very much
for coming out.
I'm sorry I'm late.
I know I cost you
billions of dollars
by being five minutes late
here and that the economy
of the world will turn on this.
It's exciting to
be here at Jewjel.
And we were at
AOL the other day,
and it's a ghost town over
there, I want to tell you that.
It's exciting to be here.
I don't know who
you are, either.
And that's the exciting part.
I wrote a book because I have
a podcast called "The Smartest
Man in the World."
Yes, it's a joke.
I don't think I'm the
smartest man in the world.
A friend of mine said to
me a couple years ago,
do you know how you come off?
And I said, no, I don't
know how I come off.
And he said, like you
bloody know everything.
So you should do a podcast
where you take questions
and brook no dissent.
So that's how it got the
name and jazz like that.
Does anyone here ever
listen to the broadcast?
Two people.
That's awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm sure you're
aware what podcasts
are because you work at Google.
And you wouldn't
work at Google if you
didn't know what a podcast was.
Do people have their phones on
during these kind of things?
Or I assume you have your phones
on at all times because that's
where all your friends are,
living in that imaginary world.
Unaccustomed as I am
to public speaking,
I feel awkward being here.
A very interesting
performing venue.
What do you usually have here?
Like drone fights or something?
It's the bizarre metal
bars that lead the way down
that make me feel like
something's going to break out
at any moment and
that there could
be some shit that goes down.
And I'm looking forward to that.
I guess maybe I should read
something from the book
if I haven't convinced
you so far that I actually
am a comedian.
I don't know how loud this mic
is or if you can even hear me.
My hearing's kind of faulty.
So I wrote the book.
And it's about all the
things that we talk about
in the podcast, like feminism
and drugs, vodka-- Thank you.
You're allowed to laugh.
I'm supposed to be funny.
Please.
Please laugh.
This isn't a cookbook.
If I get less laughs
than Padma Lakshmi,
I'm going to kill myself.
And art, literature,
ancient history, baseball,
and music I like, records
I like, books I like.
Poetry, yes, there's
poetry in here.
I know that when
you work for Google,
sometimes poetry can seep
right out of your life.
And I'm here to imbue it
back into you in this book.
We weren't able to
use all the poems I
wanted because they cost money.
But we put a lot
of poems in that
are in the public domain that
are still quite beautiful
and jazz like that.
We're going to do questions in
a minute, but let me read you
a couple things.
I asked for a
podium, but I didn't
realize I was going to be behind
Darth Vader's console here
and hiding back--
[BREATHING INTO THE MIC]
I wish you could
see this part here.
There's two monitors and
a bizarre goose-neck mic.
And then some cables that make
no sense to me whatsoever.
I wonder if I lick
the end of one of them
and stick it inside me, whether
the festivities will be more
festive when my hair lights up.
Let's see here.
I'll just read you
something from any-- oh,
there's a lexicon-- a
Proops-tionary-- of words
that I wish would
disappear and other words
that I advise people to use.
For instance, let's start there.
In the Proops-tionary,
we've got--
Words is all we gots, right?
Let's see.
I tend to speak in old-time
jive because I'm old-er.
And so I call people cats.
And sometimes I'll go like,
this cat came to the show.
And people are like, what do
you mean a cat came to the show?
And I'm like, we allow animals,
but I mean a man or a dude.
So here, I define cat. "Noun.
Not the one with four paws.
Picture Miles Davis.
Now picture him
walking away from you.
That's one mean cat.
In a sentence, 'Man that
cat, Ornette Coleman,
is nuts.' Thelonius Monk."
"Feminist.
A misunderstood word.
Feminism is simply the
idea that men and women
are equal and should
be treated like equals.
For some men, this
is truly terrifying,
like being disagreed
with or told no.
There exists a male
rights movement.
This is a nonstarter.
Men have all the rights.
Somebody needs to
learn to share."
"In a sentence, 'People call me
a feminist whenever I express
sentiments that differentiate
me from a doormat
or a prostitute.' Rebecca West."
Oligarchy, there's a word
that you hear on the news
all the time and in the media.
And I wanted to define it
because these words get
bandied around, and no one
ever tells you what they mean.
And people wander through
their whole lives never knowing
what these actually mean,
oligarchy and plutocracy
and things like that.
"A government in which
a small group exercises
control, especially for
corrupt and selfish purposes.
This could never happen.
Go back to sleep."
Polybius, the Greek historian,
said, "Monarchy degenerates
into tyranny, aristocracy
into oligarchy, and democracy
into savage violence and chaos."
That about sums it up
here in America, I think,
the savage violence and chaos.
Plutocracy-- you hear
that one bandied around--
"'a country that is ruled
by the richest people.
The most accurate word currently
in our possession.' Ramsey
Clark."
I noticed the uneasy
laughter on that one there.
I assume we're being
watched at all times here.
Let's see here.
Here's a good one.
"Freedom.
The power or right to act,
speak, or think as one
wants without
hindrance or restraint.
This term is overused by people
who do not believe in it.
It's rarely practiced
in real life.
Freedom is quite subjective.
Most people find it a bit
too much responsibility.
Governments and
large institutions
like to put parameters
on it so everyone
will feel comfortable
with not having
to think for themselves."
This is from Ambrose Bierce,
"Devil's Dictionary."
"'A political condition that
every nation supposes itself
to enjoy in virtual monopoly.'"
"Liberty.
The distinction between
freedom and liberty
is not accurately known.
Naturalists have never
been able to find
a living specimen of either."
That was a joke.
Let's see here.
I say "groovy" a lot.
And I know a lot of the kids
here think that's real arcane.
But I grew up in the '60s.
I mean, I wasn't a
teenager in the '60s.
I'm not that old.
I was a child in the '60s.
I barely remember it.
"Groovy.
Adjective.
Anything or anyone, fas
scootch that rings your chimes,
floats your lifeboat,
rubs your kitten,
or bangs your shiny bronze gong.
Groovy is associated
with kitschy '60s cliches
like bell-bottoms and headbands.
But groovy was before
and will always be.
A groove is a good
thing to be in.
When you don't have the groove,
well, it is hard to move."
In a sentence-- so I
show you how to use it--
"I loves that ambient jam.
It is so groovy.
It would be so groovy if
you filled that bong again
with the Kushberry Crunch."
Man bag is something I
use a little too much,
but I think you'll get the idea.
"The pouch where
the jewels are kept.
Pejorative, as well.
Be tender with its usage.
In a sentence, why does this
movie osculate man bag?"
That would be in
reference to any movie
that the Green Lantern is in.
"Who brought the man bag beer?
Was it that gimme-cap
over by the kiddie pool?"
Man branch, I think you'll
follow on this one, too.
"The disco stick, the candy
twig, the Tootsie Pop.
The appendage men focus
on to the exclusion
of all other things.
Where the action is.
The blissmas tree.
Co-pilot."
Thank you.
I wrote that.
I was pretty happy
with that one myself.
"Co-pilot, kickstand, love
mop, little bro, the obelisk.
In a sentence--" this is how
you would use man branch-- "Thou
villain, I invite you to take a
beefy nourishing bite of my man
branch."
This is the one I wanted
to get to, though,
because I think it's useful.
People overuse the adjective
"Orwellian" all the time.
And nobody has ever read "1984."
People have skimmed
it or whatever.
But you know the plot of "1984."
It's a futuristic society
where we're being watched
at all times by the government.
So now it's not a
futuristic society anymore.
It's kind of our society.
We're in an endless war with an
unseen enemy that'll never end.
And anyone who's against
you is a terrorist.
And Big Brother watches
you all the time.
So it's kind of like now.
"Anything that is in
opposition to a free society,
in reference to George Orwell,
author of '1984.' Overused
by those have not read Orwell.
'1984' is what people like
to call a dystopian novel.
The fallacy there is
dystopias are imaginary places
where people live in fear.
Orwell is dead, but rest
assured he's spinning
like a bobbin in his grave."
Bobbin are on a sewing machine--
I'll be explaining everything
as it goes along.
Are you on your phone?
Or are you live-tweeting this?
Because if you're live-tweeting
this, I'll dictate to you.
Greg's sexual power
was undeniable.
As he stood there,
I was reminded
of a jungle cat that gave off
emanations of testosterone.
My ovaries started
clanging like sleigh bells.
And I went off like
a volcano in Iceland.
That's over 140 characters.
Retweet.
Love.
"Noun.
We all knows it
when we feels it.
Most humans are striving
for a semblance of it.
In our current era, love is on
the ropes, what with sexting,
pornography, boy
singers, and furries."
I mean, I'm down with
the idea of dressing up
like a stuffed
animal to have sex.
It's just the smell.
And isn't it sweaty?
What do you wear-- I mean,
how much talcum powder
can you put on?
"So confusing in so
many subtle variants.
It's cool to love
roller coasters,
but hard to love vultures.
One may love fudge, but
hate brownie eaters.
Look can hurt and be in vain,
but still the most sought-after
feeling.
Love is why we
are here on Earth.
The problem is that
hate is easier for lots
of individuals than love.
It feels more comfortable, and
huge groups can do it better.
Plus, you get to carry
poorly spelled signs
and wear hoods and whatnot.
Loves is 'The Smartest
Book's' favorite usage.
In a sentence, oh my kittens,
that leather jacket-- loves.
I loves you.
I knows."
Let's see here.
This is the one I
wanted to read you.
It's at the very
beginning of the book.
There's no table of contents,
I noticed to my dismay,
when the book was published.
I had many chances to
go through the book
and amend it and rewrite
and-- what do they call it?
Edit?
But I'm a comedian so I was
busy getting high and being
in Hawaii.
So I didn't.
But then I noticed
the book came out
and there was no
table of contents.
There is, however, a
list of commandments
at the outset that tells you
what's going to be in the book.
And there's movies,
poetry, Satchel Paige.
Satchel Paige played
in the Negro leagues.
He was a baseball player who
played before the big leagues
were integrated.
Yes, there was a time in America
where black people were treated
like second class citizens.
It could never happen again.
Music, there'll be no whining.
There'll be art.
Let's see here.
And then we'll spell
woman with a capital W.
And I just wanted to read
a little bit of this.
And then we'll go into
the questions, I think.
Or if I can find something else
that's humorous, I'll read it.
You should be, Greg.
It's your book,
and you wrote it.
Well, give me-- Get off my dick.
"We will spell women
with a capital W.
There's a movement by
all men in the world
to make sure women
don't get a fair shake.
Men yell at women from cars.
Men deny women equal pay.
Men tell women to smile."
And that one really
gets me because has
a woman ever come up to
you, gentlemen, and gone,
hey, smile.
You're too cute in that
flannel shirt and the beard
not to smile.
Nice package.
You delivering that for UPS?
[GROWL] And yet, men feel free
to do it to women all the time.
And then men do things like
where phones on their belts
and expect people
to talk to them.
Men wear phones on their belts.
And then they always
have a rationale.
They're like, oh,
it's convenient.
And you're like, yeah, it is for
forming an anti-pussy perimeter
around you that no
pussy can permeate.
No woman has ever looked at a
man with a phone on his belt
and gone, oh, my god.
I bet he can answer a
call whenever he gets one.
It's more like, I bet that his
grandmother's basement where
he lives is so commodious.
He must play World of
Warcraft or The Frosty Dawn
and have all of the
"Harry Potter" figures.
Yeah, guys wear baseball
caps out at night?
Really?
Why don't you just
wear a T-shirt
that says I have roofies because
that's what the baseball cap is
saying.
The baseball cap is saying no
means yes and yes means anal.
That's what the baseball
cap is telling everyone.
Or am I to understand
that you're
a gangster from Park Slope?
Is that what's happening?
That you've rolled
into town, and you're
going to be who-banging
with your crew four deep?
Skeeting at all the fly
hos and smoking blunts?
Is that what I'm getting?
That you're going to
wet me with your jammy
if some shit goes down?
I've never understood the
baseball cap at night.
It's really-- wow.
You don't really
see women wearing
a fucking hard hat when they
go out with their girlfriends.
But they should because that's
the kind of men they run into.
That's not in the book.
But it is funny.
"Men enact laws to keep women
from health care they need.
This is not an opinion.
This is fact."
For instance, I believe that
a woman dreamed the universe
into existence.
And that's why it's
called the Big Bang
theory because
only a woman could
have had a reverberation so
profound and so cataclysmic
that the very fabric of the
cosmos was born out of that.
If a man had given
birth to the university,
it would be called the
Disappointing Early theory.
And every galaxy would
be the Milky Way.
And by the way,
this isn't a theory.
This is a fact
that I thought of.
"The reason is women dream
the universe into existence.
Women give birth.
Men take life.
If a man had done it"-- "men
can only give birth to sacred
bullets through their
Viagra-assisted man shaft.
Women deal with the
pain of childbirth.
Men act like they have
diphtheria if they get a cold.
We all know Columbus
and George Washington.
But who's talking about
Sojourner Truth or Susan B
Anthony?"
Or Shirley Chisholm,
for that matter?
"Women in the United
States could not
vote until 1920, then only
because they demanded it
for years.
Any advances women
have made, they
had done by organizing, being
better at everything than men.
Just to be recognized
and heard, they have to.
A few things to
ponder as you seek
to improve and
enlighten yourself out
of the depths of your ignorance.
Germany, New Zealand, Argentina,
India, Chile, Brazil, Pakistan,
the UK, Ireland, Canada,
and Australia--" and I'll
add Switzerland
in there as well--
"to name but a few
have had women leaders.
The USA has not.
Women, as of right, now
dominate publishing.
JK Rowling is the most
read author on Earth.
Telling a woman to smile as
an imposition and a demand
you have no right to make.
Don't Use the term 'old
lady' as a pejorative."
You hear that all the time.
It's like an old lady.
It was weak like an old lady.
I cried like an old lady.
"Old women raise the
world and know everything.
They're anything but weak.
When you go into a
bar or restaurant,
notice if the woman servers
are made to wear hot outfits.
Consider which places
make men do that."
When was the last time you went
into a bar in New York and it
was called Willie's?
And dudes were walking
around with jock straps
with butt plugs in?
Do you know what I'm saying?
But you could go to any number
of bars where women have
to skate around in mini-skirts
or whatnot so the guys can go
[SNORTING], I'll have the wings.
"Victoria's Secret
has a TV special.
Calvin Klein's
men undies do not.
Women are the majority of
the workers in the world.
That don't get equal--"
Oh, you don't have
to turn that up.
Was it me or did
the lights go up?
Or did I just hallucinate that?
All I can offer
you is the truth.
If you take the
blue pill, you'll
go back to where you were.
Let's see here.
This part's hilarious.
"Women are regularly assaulted,
raped, beaten, abused,
murdered, sold, and
disappeared everywhere.
That means in America as well.
This is not the top
story in the news ever."
It's my assertion that if women
were looked after and made
equal and there were
some sort of parity,
that that would solve all
the problems of the world.
I'm not sure why
everyone doesn't see it
the way I do other than
everyone does have no vision
and I have progressives.
Thank you.
Progressives are
the glasses that--
Because when you look out--
Let me put it this way.
When it's as easy
to get an abortion
as it is to obtain a
gun, then you can tell me
there's equity in the world.
And the reason why it's
so easy to get guns
is because men love guns
because men want guns.
But guns are to protect
our safety and freedom.
Mhm.
That hasn't really happened yet.
I never feel safe
when guns are around.
And I don't feel like my
safety or freedom is protected.
Guns are for men to kill people
they're afraid of, as far as I
can figure out.
And for the rich
to get the police
to kill the poor
on behalf of them.
Thank you for laughing at that.
I appreciate that.
It is a joke.
And it's also true.
Let's see here.
"There'll be good
drugs and good times."
We talk about drugs
and drink in the book.
"Light one up and pour
one down, and let's all
get together and put
on wings like Icarus
and see how high
we can go to night
before the horrible
flaming demon sun
that man made out of this
hideous nuclear agenda
burns our delicate
artistic wings
and sends our sensitive
behinds spiraling back
to the ground like a burned
McNugget full of regret.
Or let's just horse around
until something funny happens.
And if you're clean and
sober, hurray for you.
Be a lamb chop, and
go get the corkscrew.
Oh, and fill the ice
bucket, will you, Darling?
You can drive
everyone home later."
I think we've had enough
reading from the book.
I know I have.
Does anyone want
to do questions?
I think there's a microphone.
Do people have to go
over to the microphone?
Or is someone going to walk
around with the microphone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GREG PROOPS: Oh, they
have to walk up to it?
Oh, OK.
Will people walk up to the mic?
Actually you don't have to.
You can just yell it out.
This is a pretty small room.
No one has any questions?
You're going to let me stand
here for-- There you are.
Well done, sir.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming to Google.
Clearly, you don't
get enough chance
to do stand-up
and improv comedy.
But I've loved following
your improv before.
GREG PROOPS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: What are you
enjoying doing most right now?
GREG PROOPS: The podcast
is my favorite thing to do,
although I'm really
enjoying this book
tour because the chance to
talk about yourself endlessly
and how clever you are is a
rare opportunity to feed my ego.
And of course, if
you're a comedian,
there's that particular quirk
of having the gaping void where
a personality is.
And instead I want to
shallow love of strangers.
Every 15 to 30 seconds.
I demand their approval.
And it's a particular
kind of sickness.
But I love the
podcast most of all
because it combines
improvisation, which I usually
riff it, and then I can go into
the boring, preachy part where
I talk about all my
poisoned liberal politics.
And I don't have to get
a laugh every 30 seconds.
When you do stand-up,
there's a real demand
that you get a laugh every 30
seconds because the audience,
that's what they're there
to-- and they have every right
to expect it.
They paid money for that.
But with the podcast,
I can stretch it
out a little bit more.
And also, we had the chance
to go all over the world.
Like we did a podcast
in Brooklyn last night.
Brooklyn is where you guys live.
And then we're in Philly, which
is where some of you are from.
And then we're going to Chicago,
San Diego, Portland, San
Francisco.
Last year, we were in Amsterdam,
Stockholm, Helsinki, Paris,
London, Edinburgh,
Toronto, Montreal.
So it gives me the chance
to go around the world.
And it's because of the
magic of the inter-web
and the smartphone.
You don't have to be on
telly anymore and all that.
There's that
immediate connection
that we all have because
of the instantaneous nature
and the on-demand nature
of putting out a podcast.
People listen to it in
their car or when they're
walking their dog
or whatever they're
doing in any country
all of the world.
So I found that technology is
a fantastic boon to comedy,
and that the personal
nature of the podcast.
It's like a phone conversation.
Many of you have had them.
Most of you just
text now, but you
know what I'm talking about.
What I mean is the intimacy
of talking into someone's ear.
Because I don't think of it
as a giant group of people.
I think of it as
talking to individuals.
And that's what's made
it so profound for me.
I talk about poetry a lot
on the show, and drugs.
And people give me books
about poetry and drugs.
And it's really nice.
Sometimes at the same time.
Thank you for asking.
By the way, "Whose Line" is
back on, if you were wondering.
It's on the CW now.
So if you like vampires,
we're on your network, baby.
I don't know about night
of the week it's on,
but it's on one of them.
And it's still all this us.
It's bald guy, the black
guy, the tall guy, and me.
Thank you.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: As a man who
knows everything, does
that mean you have a rivalry--
GREG PROOPS: Are you
speaking for you yourself,
or are you addressing me?
AUDIENCE: As you, as you.
So do you have a
rivalry with John
Hodgman, who also believes--
GREG PROOPS: Oh, not at all.
No.
John and I get
along really well.
His neck beard is a
little off-putting.
But no, he's a
judge of everything.
There's a big difference.
I adjudicate from time to time,
but mostly I just pontificate.
And so I'm happy to have him sit
on the Supreme Court of comedy.
And if it was my choice, he
would be an associate justice.
I wouldn't make him chief
justice because he's a man.
But I love John Hodgman.
He's very funny.
I don't know what he
does, but it's wonderful.
Well, that concludes the
question portion of the show.
I'm going to stand here
awkwardly and stare at you
for the next half hour now.
Does anyone else want
to ask a question?
I'm happy to answer them.
I really am.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
GREG PROOPS: There you are.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: First of
all, you're awesome.
Thank you.
GREG PROOPS: Thank you.
That is correct.
AUDIENCE: Your podcast--
GREG PROOPS: And humble.
Fuck.
AUDIENCE: --shows that you're
essentially a Renaissance man.
You're interested
in a lot of topics.
So how did you decide
what topics you
were going to put into
the book out of the sum
total of history, I guess?
GREG PROOPS: Thank
you for that question.
It was very difficult
to choose which ones.
But I knew that the
initial ones would
be books and records, movies.
And my wife and I do the Greg
Proops Film Club as well.
We show pictures
every-- I mean, movies.
I told you I talked in jive.
You know, motion pictures.
We show pictures every month in
Los Angeles at the Cinefamily.
And a lot of the movies that
we talk about on that podcast
are in this book as well.
It was the ancient
history chapters
because I tend to draw
analogies all the time
between ancient Greece
and Rome and now.
Ancient Rome was embroiled in
a series of wars in the Middle
East in Afghanistan
that destroyed
their empire and
their slave culture
and their lack of forward
thinking and their belief
that all other foreign
cultures were barbarians
and that they were the
superior culture in the world
and that their Senate was
bought-and-sold, paid-for rich
oligarchs who were working
at the behest of the emperor.
So you get the analogy.
So I wrote these
Leviathan chapters
on Julius Caesar and
Alexander the Great.
And my editor Matthew
is here today.
We cut them down.
They were a
gajillion words long.
So that was one thing.
And then there was a few
other-- I would always
talk about stealing art.
My wife and I were at a museum
in Paris called the Marmottan.
It was a fabulous museum.
It's full Monets and all
these beautiful French
impressionists.
And there was an open window
and a parking lot right there.
And I was like,
Jennifer, I'm going
to have a petit mal seizure.
And you grab a
picture off the wall
and throw it out
the fucking window.
And I'll meet you
downstairs in five minutes.
And then we'll get
a bus out of here.
And I thought it would be
that easy to steal art.
So I started talking
about it on the show.
And then I realized,
it's a very shaky slope
to encourage people
to steal fine art.
And so I don't encourage
anyone to steal art
unless your plan is foolproof,
in which case meet me outside.
I'm in a van.
It has a horse
painted on the side.
And I answer to Miguel.
But that's how
most art is stolen.
So I didn't know how to
approach that chapter.
And Matthew said to
me, why don't you
call it "10 Pieces of Art I
Wish I had the Balls to Steal."
And so that's how
that got in there.
So that was kind of the process.
And it's one of my
favorite chapters.
And I only chose
pieces of art so large,
you couldn't
possibly steal them.
Let me just read you
one here that I think
is my favorite one.
"El Mundo Magico de los
Mayas" by Leonora Carrington.
It was at the Museum National
of Anthropology in Mexico City.
Leonora Carrington,
blah, blah, blah.
Every single one of them is
how we're going to steal,
what the piece of art is,
and the chances of success.
"She was given a
commission to do
a mural about the pre-white
people history of Mexico
and went to Chiapas
to study the area.
She was introduced by the
anthropologist Gertrude Blom
to the curanderos, or healers,
from the awesomely named town
of Zinacantan.
That means the land of bats.
They normally didn't do
their thing for outsiders,
but Ms. Carrington had
such a vast knowledge
and respect for mysticism and
healing, they let her sit in.
She studied the 'Popol
Vuh,' or people's history,
which is the Mayan sacred
book of mysteries before
the Conquistadors.
From this, she painted
'The Magical World
of the Mayas,'
which is enormous.
The painting resides
in Chapultepec Park
in Mexico City.
So we should take a shamanistic
dose of psychoactive mushrooms
that we have bought
from a lady named
Carmalita we met in a bodega.
We get too high
and start to freak,
so we stop for
frescoes at a stand.
The afternoon is still and
we can hear children playing.
So your sense of
dread abates somewhat.
And we sally to the museum.
There in the warm glow
of altered perception,
we become overwhelmed
by the astounding colors
and fantastical motif.
Imbued with a sense of
belonging to the universe,
we abandon our notion
of physical theft
and decide to have an unlikely
escapade in a brightly colored
cab.
Later, when we're coming down,
we have seafood enchiladas
and revel in our re-found
sense of cosmic morality.
So goes the flow.
Chance of success?
Mythical, like the
lizard god returning."
So you see that we don't
actually steal things
in every single part.
Sometimes we just get high
and ride around in a cab.
This is my favorite one now.
And this is given to me by a
drugged-up friend in Montreal.
I was working there last summer.
And I told him I was writing
a chapter on stealing art.
And he said what about
George W Bush's paintings?
And I was, like, well, where
are George W Bush's paintings?
And how does one steal them?
Paintings.
George W Bush.
2010.
Dick Cheney's fridge, Wyoming.
"George W Bush was almost
voted president twice
during the terror war
depression boom of the 2000s.
Dick Cheney was
nominally vice president,
but in reality he
was the shot caller.
Since his retirement
from public life,
W's has been his goal of
being the worst artist who
ever held office since Hitler.
His portraits of world
leaders he has met
are a tribute to the
primitive school of art brut,
or outsider art, usually
meaning art made by people
from without the art world, such
as children or mental patients.
Cheney's house in Wyoming
is filled with trophies
and war crime memorabilia.
We'd pitch up as an honor
guard with a band, uniforms
and everything.
We'd perform a
number on the lawn
and ask to use the facilities.
On our way to the loo, we'd
steal the Putin portrait
off the refrigerator
and drive like fury.
We can be at the Devil's
Tower-- non-ironic-- before noon
and then freedom.
Win-win.
Chance of success?
Like winning a war
in Afghanistan."
[AUDIENCE GROANS]
Oh, golly.
That one must have really hurt.
Walk it the fuck
off, Google person.
[LAUGHTER]
So you get the idea on
the art theft chapter.
Really?
If that was harsh for you,
what's the "Daily World"
like in New York for you?
This isn't the sweetest
city in the world.
And any other questions?
And then I think-- I don't
know how long this goes--
then we're going to--
[WHISTLE]
--sign books and shit like that.
Oh, Jesus Christ.
Don't ever sneak up
on me like that again.
Yes, sir?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned poetry.
And as like probably much of
this audience, I'm an engineer.
And I've really
never got poetry.
I've attempted.
It's like jazz.
It's too beyond me.
You know what?
I just don't get it.
GREG PROOPS: Right.
AUDIENCE: Can you help me?
GREG PROOPS: Yes, of course.
You're exactly the
kind of individual
that this is aimed at.
I realize that the demands
of work and making a living
and just surviving
preclude a lot
of poetry in people's lives.
And that's why I think
there's poetry in everything.
Inside your phone, of course,
all your imaginary friends live
and all the pretend people
that you think you know.
But if you look up
in the sky, there's
a moon almost every night,
and stars, and wind.
And you look around
New York, and then,
oh, look, a giant rat.
And I wonder where
that rat's going.
And then you think about, oh,
the rat's going to the subway.
And then inside the subway,
there's filth and whatnot.
And look at the filth, how
it forms little swirls.
So there's poetry,
really, in everything.
You see flowers when
you're in New York.
People have planted
flowers in flower boxes.
Or you go to Union Square,
and the other day I
saw a dude dancing to "Rock
With You" by Michael Jackson
in front of the statue
of George Washington.
And so he's found his
own poetry right here
in this giant-ass ghetto
that is New York and shit.
You may remember the
movie-- did you ever
see the movie "Willy Wonka"?
Not the Johnny Depp one, where
he's a pervert, but the Gene
Wilder one.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
GREG PROOPS: You
saw that one, right?
And remember, they're licking
the wallpaper, and he goes,
the raspberries taste
like raspberries,
the snozzberries taste
like snozzberries.
And the little horrible
rich girl goes, there's
such thing as a snozzberry.
And he grabs her face and he
goes, we are the music makers.
And we are the
dreamers of dreams,
wandering by lone sea breakers
or sitting by desolate streams,
world movers and
world foresakers
on whom the pale moon gleams.
Yet we are the movers and
shakers of the world forever
it seems.
So you have to be a music maker.
That's what the world's about.
I understand that
poetry is bloody hard
to get your mind around.
I don't know if this
has helped you at all.
I'm trying to find a poem
in here that-- there's
a poem in here that is so bloody
long that Matthew, the editor,
was like, you've got to write
a long intro to this poem
'cause this poem takes
for-fucking-ever.
So this was my suggestion.
It's William Blake.
Now William Blake--
Sit down, young lady.
I'm going to come
to your cubicle
and then fucking stand
there and then leave.
Well, I guess there's something
more exciting going on
in the Google building, like
an endless series of numbers
of the matrix that she has
to get back to at her fucking
console.
AUDIENCE: The Albanian
president is here today.
GREG PROOPS: Who is?
AUDIENCE: The
Albanian president.
GREG PROOPS: Really?
Again?
You know, I can't shake
that son of a bitch.
Everywhere I've
been in New York,
there's been a Balkan
leader tagging on me.
I had the defense minister
of [INAUDIBLE] two days ago
at my show.
I've been to Albania
and trust me-- mm.
The Balkans are rough going.
There's no dogs.
Why, Greg?
Because there's so much
unexploded ordinance
in the ground from
their giant war
that you don't see any
fucking animals anywhere.
Well, I just thought I'd add
that note of-- poetry, was it,
we were talking about?
So you're telling me
that young lady split
in the middle of a presentation
during the lunch hour
to go meet the
president of Albania?
No, you're just suggesting
that he was here.
I don't even know
what his name is.
Do we know what his name is?
Albania had a king
up until the '40s.
And his name was Zog.
And he was played by Terence
Stamp in the "Superman" movie.
King Zog is such a great name.
I'm thinking of
changing my name.
William Blake, or as they say
in the movie "Bull Durham,"
William Blake.
William Blake?
William Blake!
"William Blake saw
God when he was four.
He had amazing hallucinations.
At 10, he announced he
was going to be a painter.
He took up poetry.
One of his assignments was
to sketch the tombstones
at Westminster Abbey.
He was a real free thinker.
He wrote much about it and he
hanged out--" or, I say here,
"he rolled with Thomas Paine."
Thomas Paine wrote
"Common Sense"
that helped us
overthrow the British.
"And Mary Wollstonecraft."
Mary Wollstonecraft was
Mary Shelley's mother.
And she was a feminist
from the 18th century.
"Blake was working
on illustrations
for Dante's 'Divine
Comedy.'" Let's see here.
"This joint is
lengthy, but it rhymes.
And you have to bend some of
the words to make them rhyme.
I suggest the William
Blake cocktail--
two ounces of anything
hard, wave your hand
over the glass,
gaze at the heavens,
and swallow all at once."
I won't read the whole thing
because it's really long.
But I'll read you
a couple of lines.
"To see a world in a
grain of sand and heaven
in a wild flower, hold infinity
in the palm of your hand
and eternity in an hour."
Now we've already experienced
eternity in an hour just now.
So I think you can understand
where that one's coming from.
And this is the
one that I always
think about when I think
about America and the way
we're inching toward oblivion
by ignoring that there's
poor people in this country.
Oh, if I can find the
bloody line there.
Well, this is the line that you
hear often from William Blake.
"Every morning, every night,
some are born to sweet delight.
Some are born to sweet delight.
Some are born to endless night.
We're led to believe
a lie when we
see not through the eye,
which was born in a night
to perish in a night when the
soul slept in beams of light.
God appears and God is light
to those poor souls who
dwell in night but does a
human form display to those
who dwell in realms of day.
The one that I
always remember is
the dog starved at
the master's gate
predicts the ruin of the state.
I don't know if that helps you
at all, but thank you-- Oh,
you've sat down now.
And you've disappeared.
Thank you for asking that
question about poetry.
Yes, aren't you the person
who brought me here?
AUDIENCE: I am.
But I also have a question.
GREG PROOPS: Oh, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
obviously, you're at Google.
And you're obviously
not very opinionated.
GREG PROOPS: No.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to get your opinion
on what you might tell
engineers who are here who
have helped you write the book.
What's your favorite
Google product?
Who has helped you
write the book?
What has helped you
publish the book here?
Let's bring this
back to the book.
GREG PROOPS: Your question
makes no sense at all.
And I appreciate that.
I did use a computer when
I was writing the book.
But I didn't use Wikipedia
or anything like that.
I used other books as resources.
And I also went on websites
specific to the people
that I was studying and not--
Wikipedia, I find, is erroneous.
How do I know so?
Because I have a Wikipedia
page of my minor fame.
And it has everything
wrong about me.
And I had a web friend
who was a web expert.
And I gave him an actual bio
that put all the facts straight
on it.
And he submitted
it to Wikipedia.
And they rejected it and
gave it back and went, no, we
don't want that bio.
And I'm like, but I wrote it.
It's my life, and I
know what happened.
And they're like uh-huh.
This is what happened.
So that's why I
didn't use Wikipedia.
I also have Gmail.
If you wish to write me, it's
fanmailforgreg@gmail.com.
And I ask everyone who
writes me on my Gmail
to say hello to the
NSA because it's
almost certain that the NSA
is collecting that data.
And so people write very
funny things like, go
fuck yourself and--
AUDIENCE: Say NSA,
I fucked your mom.
GREG PROOPS: Yeah,
exactly, like the NSA
has a mom, which I love.
But I think it's a very
useful tool, the search
engine and whatnot.
I also find books
are a dandy resource.
And that people are
often a good resource.
They're not a factual resource
because people say things like,
I think I read this somewhere.
Or, I might have
heard this somewhere.
So that's why I wrote this
book, so that you can go,
I've read it in
Greg Proops' book.
And I say, you can say to
your friends, I read it here
and it's on page
whatever, whatever.
But I do appreciate
that there are engineers
because I couldn't do your job.
A lot of people go, how can
you be a stand-up comic?
And it's easy.
You just have to
have an unlimited ego
and no sense of embarrassment.
I could never get on stage.
And I'm always like, good,
there's too many of us.
Stay off the fucking stage.
And I could never be an engineer
because I can never focus
and I have no ability
at math whatsoever.
And my ADD precludes sitting
in one place for a long time.
I worked in a law office for
several years as a schmendrick.
Thank you, for the
Jews in the house.
And I didn't like it.
This was in the '80s.
And there was no computers then.
There were word processors
and fax machines.
And I used to make jewelery
out of paper clips.
And I remember being so
bored and hateful at my job,
at one point I laid on
the floor and pretended I
was dead for maybe 45 minutes.
And no one walked
into the cubicle.
So it might have been the
saddest part of my life.
I was like, I am
going to show them how
this job is destroying my soul.
And I laid on the floor,
and no one fucking came in.
Finally, I got up off the
floor, dusted myself off,
put my paper clip
jewelry on, and went back
to my job of putting
toner in the copy machine.
But I'm appreciative
that you've come out.
Is everyone here an engineer?
AUDIENCE: No.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Advertising
also, which is awesome.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No it's not.
GREG PROOPS: I understand.
I am, of course,
advertising my book,
so I cannot gainsay you
in any way right now.
And from the position I'm
standing in, selling my wares
as it were, there's
no way I can diminish
you working in advertising.
Later, of course, on the
comedy club stage, yes.
But here and now, not so much.
Does that answer
your question at all?
AUDIENCE: Yes, yes.
GREG PROOPS: I own a computer.
And I own a phone.
So, you know, hey.
I got Netflix and shit.
I'm down with the kids.
I'm learning.
I don't know that I have
a favorite Google product.
The word Google is
kind of exciting.
It's an infinite thing,
Googleplex and all that.
Thank you.
What's your question, sir?
AUDIENCE: My question
is that I've never
seen comedians laugh to their
jokes, or even laugh at all.
GREG PROOPS: I didn't
hear what you said.
You didn't what?
AUDIENCE: I've
never seen comedians
laugh at all to their jokes.
Or even when you laugh, like
[IMITATING GREG'S LAUGH] done,
or [IMITATING GREG'S LAUGH]
done.
And everybody else is laughing.
How does that filter?
Is there any joke in-- Is
that taught as to comedians?
Is it like, hey, you're going
to be comedian-- never laugh?
GREG PROOPS: Oh, no, I think--
AUDIENCE: Are there
any jokes that you
have really laughed and banged
your tummy on the floor?
We would like to hear
about those jokes rather
than those jokes which you
have made others laugh.
What are the jokes that
have made you laugh?
I have never seen you laugh.
GREG PROOPS: We do laugh.
We do laugh.
I laugh at lots
of people's jokes.
And my wife's very funny.
And I laugh at lots
of comedians' jokes.
But in general, no.
The joke is about comedians.
A comic could be
on stage killing,
and the other comedians
turn to each other and go,
that's funny.
But you guys are engineers.
When someone comes up with
a Leviathan calculation that
solves some sort of
equation, does everyone
gather around and fucking
do a lap of honor and shit?
No.
You just nod sagely
at one another and go,
yes, you certainly
cracked that one open.
So it's because we're in
the profession of laughter
that we don't necessarily
get all giggly all the time.
We're a little more
judicious and professional
in assaying what the
other person has said.
Having said that, I laugh
at lots of different jokes.
And I have lots of
favorite comedians.
I was quoting a Mark
Maron joke last night
where he said-- we were
talking about the podcasting.
And right now, we're able
to say whatever we want.
But soon the
governmental will get hip
to the fact that were
talking seditious smack
and try to shut us down.
Someone at the SEC will be
assigned to listen to podcasts.
And they're going to
have an enormous job
of sifting through Chris
Hardwick talking about
"The Walking Dead"
for 1,000 years
and finding what's
wrong with that.
And Mark Maron's joke was, if
there is an FBI agent assigned
to me, he's the saddest FBI
agent in the whole agency.
Subject got up in the morning,
masturbated, and then cried
for several hours.
[LAUGHTER]
[SNORT]
Yes, I slapped my thigh as well.
That was-- That one
really made me laugh
when I heard it the first time.
Bill Hicks always has
lots of jokes that
really make me laugh out loud.
What's that?
One of my favorites is he
has these jokes about Jesus.
He goes, you think
if Jesus came back,
he'd really want to see
everyone wearing a crucifix?
It'd be like walking around
with a gun around your neck
and you see Jackie
Kennedy and you go, just
thinking about John, right?
[LAUGHTER]
These are Bill Hicks'
jokes, not mine.
And God bless Bill Hicks.
He's gone now, but-- So he goes,
I'm doing these jokes one night
and a bar in Texas and these
rednecks come up to me.
And they go, hey, come here.
Boom.
And he goes, why do people
always push you away
when they say come here?
Hey, come here.
Boom.
We're Christians.
And we didn't like what
you said about Jesus.
And we're going
to kick your ass.
And he goes, well, if you're
Christians, forgive me.
And that joke, I thought,
was hysterically funny.
That one made me laugh out loud
because it's a profound joke
about Christianity.
And what is it?
The one about anti-abortionists?
If you're so pro-life, why don't
you go all the way and lock
arms around a cemetery?
[LAUGHS] No one fucking
dies on our watch.
[SNORT]
George Carlin had one, too,
that made me cry laughing.
He goes, what is
this with Dan Akroyd
and all these middle-aged
white guys opening
the House of Blues?
He says, white people
have to understand.
We're not here to
sing the blues.
We're here to give
people the blues.
[LAUGHS]
So those are the kind of jokes.
What was Lily Tomlin's one?
Lily Tomlin said, when I was
young, I wanted to be somebody.
Now I realize I should've
been more specific.
[SNORT]
I'm getting a lot of mileage
off other geniuses' jokes
that aren't mine.
This is fantastic, just
reciting shit I remembered.
Thank you for your question.
I appreciate it.
Yes, sir?
No women want to ask anything?
All right.
Whatever.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: A technical question.
When you're doing the song
improv, you get up there.
And you get the topic.
And you have 10 seconds to come
up with a verse that rhymes.
Is there a technique?
I just think that's impossible.
I don't know how you do that.
GREG PROOPS: Well,
it's not, because we've
done it a long time.
We've all worked together
for a thousand years.
And your brain just
tries to click into gear.
My friend Jeff
Davis always says,
say the first thing that
comes into your mind
because that's usually
the funniest thing.
The rhyming part is a little
difficult occasionally.
I mean, with Wayne Brady,
he's extraordinary.
And he can make up anything
right then and there.
He's not goofing around.
And we don't edit it out.
Like people go, oh you guys
couldn't possibly make it
up the way you do.
Not only do we do it, we
get four or five shows out
of a two-hour taping.
We play maybe 25 games.
And then the rest of
it's camera in and out.
That's all it is.
So the editing, right?
So that we can--
The show is modular.
So whatever bit we do,
whatever improv we do,
can be put with whatever,
any bit from any other part
of the show.
So that you could put a whole
bunch of shows together.
So there's always Aisha
going, when we come back,
when we come back, this, now
there's this, now there's this.
So that's how we make
the show, that format.
So we spend more time getting up
and standing up and going back
and sitting down than
we do improvising
so that the show
can be put together
in any particular order that
they need to put it together
in.
Having said, we rarely
throw anything away.
Once in a while there's
a miscue or someone
says fuck or something.
And then they stop camera.
And that's how, if I
can't think anything
and we're doing a hoedown or one
of those awful fucking things--
By the way, hoedowns
are our least favorite.
And I'm not the only one.
We were playing in Alberta,
Canadia, the other night.
And someone yelled hoedown
out from the audience.
And Ryan Stiles went, I got
your hoedown right here, right?
Like, Ryan hates
the fucking hoedown.
That's how-- if I can't think
of anything and I freak out
and I don't have
a rhyme, I'll go,
I fucking, fucking, fucking.
And they go, cut.
And then you get to go back
and go right, right, right.
What rhymes with wedge?
And then come back out
and give it another go.
So we're doing it off
the top of our head.
And we're doing it in real time.
And nothing gets cut
out of the improvs
and ends up on the floor.
They are not cutting
the improvs together
to make them look like
we're improvising them.
We really are improvising
them all the time.
And I'm not just saying it.
We've been doing
it for 100 years.
I've been on the show for--
We started 25 years ago
when I was 11.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a science.
You know what I mean?
Our producer is a scientist.
He's made the show
this modular thing
that can be put in with
different building blocks.
This, this, this.
The reason why I think me
and Ryan and Colin and Wayne
and Brad and whomever are
still on it after 25 years
is that it's difficult to find
people who can play that way.
Our producer's an extremely
nervous individual.
And we add new people to
the cast every once a while.
But you have to be
able to go like that.
It's a shark tank.
We're supportive.
We're not mean.
We don't cut each
other off at the knees.
But we bounce pass backwards
with our eyes closed
like the Lakers of the '80s.
And the Lakers are a--
that's a sports team.
Sports are-- Well, anyway,
so that's how that works.
I don't know how I can
describe the mental process
of being able to think
of a rhyme immediately.
But I know when I'm
playing with Jeff on stage
and we have to sing a song
together, and they go,
oh, this was a country
western classic.
And it's all about teachers.
And it's called "I Love
You and Your Apple."
And like he'll go to me,
just get out there and go,
[SINGING] School, school,
taught me not to be a fool.
Or whatever.
You know, like that's it.
You just jump right in and
then hopefully something
happens in your mind and
you're able to think of it.
And you have to be
confident freefalling.
Keith Johnstone, who
is a guru of improv,
said that improv is walking
backwards down the road
because you only know
where you've been.
So you're like
this all the time.
I don't know where I'm going,
but I know where I've been.
So that's how we
kind of approach it.
And every scene in the
world is about status.
So when you walk into a scene
and there's someone in there,
are you a higher than them?
Are you lower than them?
Are you their mother?
Are you their father?
Are you their son?
Are you their employee?
Are you their--
So that's how every
interaction works.
And if you don't
think so, when you
walk back to where you're
going to work today,
the first person that you
meet, think about that.
The first person you run into,
are you an equal with them?
Are you above them?
Are you below--
You know what I mean?
And I don't mean economically.
I just mean socially,
like human-ly.
If you walk by someone and
they're cleaning the floor,
do you stop and help
them clean the floor?
No, you fucking don't.
Because that's their job.
And dah-dah-dah-dah-dah.
And if you walk by and your
boss walks by, do you go, hey,
fuck you.
I'm sick of it.
No, you don't.
Because they're your boss.
You go, hi, good
morning, Mr. Gunderson.
And what a lovely day today.
And what a lovely corporate
mantel you're wearing,
and shit like that.
So I hope I haven't
told you too much.
Talking about improv is like
watching hot dogs get made.
It's icky.
Thank you, sir.
And that's it.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask--
GREG PROOPS: Not one woman?
Oh, hi.
You're back.
AUDIENCE: I'm back.
Do you have favorite
improv game?
GREG PROOPS: Well, I like
the film and theater styles
because you get
to change genres,
But we don't do that
one much anymore.
They tend to do a lot of that.
We're still doing
weird newscasters.
The one that makes me laugh
the hardest is the dating one.
We're still doing
the dating one.
And I'm always the woman.
So I'm always like,
bachelor number two,
if I was steamed broccoli, what
would you pour all over me?
And like, we've been doing
this for fucking 25 years.
And the audience cries
laughing every time.
And you're like, surely
you've figured this one out.
And then it'll be
like-- Colin'll be like,
thinks he's inside a sandwich,
or whatever fucking nonsense
they've come up.
[NONSENSE SOUNDS]
And the place is
fucking falling apart.
And I'm always like, Jesus
Christ, surely this joke's
done.
But it never is.
So that's the
infinity of improv.
AUDIENCE: You've
shamed me into this.
GREG PROOPS: Hello, darling.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
As a human and as
a person, I truly
appreciate all your
comments on feminism.
Thank you very much.
GREG PROOPS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: But I'm wondering,
as you go out into the world
and as you're meeting
so many people
and doing things like
this, how does the feminism
play in those jokes
and in the rooms?
How does it play in person?
GREG PROOPS: Better than
it always has, I think.
People are more involved
now, more enlightened.
And the guys that are resistant
to it and are upset by it
tend to be a little
quieter now because they
can catch the overwhelming
drift in the wind.
Having said that,
I was in Boston
several weeks ago, which is a
small inferior city near here.
The Bostonians on the night we
did the podcast were lovely.
I'd received more poetry books
than any gig I've ever done.
I mean, a dozen poetry books.
And no one would let me move.
They surrounded me and were
pressing poetry books on me,
and marijuana.
And it was fantastic.
Then the stand-up weekend came.
And it was people who didn't
know why they were there.
They didn't come to
see me in particular.
They just came to see comedy.
Or because they'd
run out of roofies,
whatever the situation was.
And so they were there.
And a lot of couples,
you know, whatnot.
And the guys of Boston tend
to be a little unevolved,
if I can generalize.
I'm not saying
everyone in Boston.
Well, what about Harvard
and Cambridge and all that?
No one who goes to Harvard in
Cambridge comes to this club.
I assure you of that.
And if they do, they're in
charge of lethargy at Harvard.
Indifference, I
teach difference.
So I was doing this bit about
the woman dreaming the universe
into existence and all that.
And I did a lengthy
bit about guys
yelling at women from cars.
And how every woman
in the world is
familiar with the
experience of you're
carrying your
laundry in a basket.
And all you want to do
is get to the laundromat.
And a truck pulls up
and a guy goes, nice ass
[NONSENSE SOUNDS] and all that.
And the guy in the back yells
out, what are you, a woman?
That was his heckle.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
GREG PROOPS: And it was
like, wow, what are you?
Unempathetic?
I didn't even respond
to it because I've never
heard anything--
I mean, I really
expected to see a club in
his hand and a unibrow.
You know what I mean?
If that's your heckle,
what do you do at night?
Oh, right.
You draw bison on a wall
and reenact the hunt.
So occasionally, I
do you run into it.
Here's something along that line
that you may find interesting.
And it'll be the first
thing in today's talk.
I'm joking, of course.
Talking about the dominant
paradigm of the United States
and that the rich are
taking all the money
and that billionaires or the
1%, and the 0.1% of the 1%,
is taking all the money
and the rest of us
will have to scrabble,
if I introduced that
on television or in
a radio interview
or in a print interview
five years ago,
I would be contested on it.
People would go, no, that's
not how the world works.
And now no one ever does.
And I think it's a
function of what's
happened in the last eight
years, the end of the Cheney
administration,
and what happened
when Romney ran and Romney got
caught out saying, you know,
there's people that think
they're entitled to food.
That was a very big moment
in American society.
And I think a lot of people--
like, for instance, you guys
are New Yorkers.
Hurricane Sandy
hit, and everyone
in New York and New
Jersey came out and voted
for Obama in that last election
because people recognized
with Mitt Romney,
maybe he wasn't
an innately evil individual, but
he was a billionaire defending
the interests of billionaires.
And they said to him,
well, what about the women?
And he went, I got
binders full of women.
That was exactly the
wrong thing to say.
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
GREG PROOPS: To 50%
of the population,
what do you mean
I'm in a binder?
That's how you look at me?
And so they give glimpses all
the time, the dominant class,
of where they're coming from.
And when they do, it
informs everybody.
So gradually-- to answer your
question a long-winded way--
I think it's eroding.
And that yeah, there's lots
of unreconstructed guys
who want hot chicks.
And they want the
Swedish bikini team.
And they want to watch football.
And they don't care
that football's
an unpolice group of
corporate zillionaires
who got these big
behemoths out there beating
each other to death and they
don't do anything for them
to deal with sexual
assault and all that shit,
and they can look the other
way because it's entertainment.
So I hope that
answers your question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GREG PROOPS: It's getting
better and better all the time.
And the preponderance of
dominant female comedians
is making the playing
field awesome.
Now there's Amy Schumer and Amy
Poehler and everyone named Amy.
And all my friends, Jen
Kirkman and Margaret Cho.
It's just fantastic.
When I first started, when
TV was powered by steam,
there wasn't-- you'd go to do
a weekend at a club and it was
sure to be you and two
other guys, always.
And usually two
other white guys.
And now it's not
always that way.
You often find there's
as many women as men.
Even "Whose Line," which
is the most recherche retro
show in the world,
where four men pretend
to be women with each
other because there's
no women in the cast, they've
been putting more women in.
And now sometimes there's an
equal number of black people
and white people on the
show, and an equal number
of men and women on the
show, which there never
was on the old one.
It was just white guys.
And not even that many Jews.
Let's be fucking honest.
For a comedy show with no Jews?
Wow.
How did you even engineer that?
So I hope that
answers your question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Thank you.
GREG PROOPS: Thank you.
Hi, darling.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: My name is Molly.
GREG PROOPS: Hi, Molly.
AUDIENCE: And I'm really
into your outspoken feminism
as well.
GREG PROOPS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You're
clearly in improv.
And I find this problem.
I'm walking down the street.
I walk past somebody and
they're like, damn, girl.
And then 15 paces later, I'm
like, what should I say back?
I'm too late.
Do you have something
improv-style
that I could just
have at the ready?
Just to say to them--
GREG PROOPS: Oh, I see.
Oh, you mean--
AUDIENCE: As they harass
me, I, afterwards, am like,
what should I have said?
How can I let them know
that it's unacceptable,
inappropriate.
I'm annoyed.
And that they're
coming off like a fool.
But it's always too late.
And then I think of a
million things after.
GREG PROOPS: What are the
things you think of after?
AUDIENCE: I want to stop
them and be like, excuse me,
what's your name?
Does that work?
Why did you do that?
Was I doing something that
made you think that I wanted
to hear what you thought?
Even that's kind
of scary to do when
you're like in this
not always warm city.
You don't want to stop them
and engage them because what
if they punch you in the face?
GREG PROOPS: Well, that's
what my thought-- My
first thought was that.
It depends on who's
yelling it out.
I would be leery of even
stopping and engaging
with some of these.
AUDIENCE: Usually large, older
men would be the demographic.
GREG PROOPS: Sadly.
My generation is
going to die off soon,
and it's going to be so great.
I can't wait for Dick Cheney's
generation to die off.
And then when they die
off, it'll be better.
But then when we die off,
it'll be even better.
Because I really
believe young people
are not going to care about gay
marriage or medical marijuana
or abortion or any of that shit.
That's all going
to be a non-issue,
this big heel-dragging thing.
The first thing I would yell
back at a guy is like, oh,
I didn't know you were gay.
And that's, of
course, homophobic.
But then you can say--
AUDIENCE: I know.
I don't want to play that angle.
GREG PROOPS: I was going
to yell something at you,
but you're so inconceivably
ugly that my tongue was tied.
Or you could yell
back at them, wow,
that was like Oscar
Wildean in its wit.
I defer to you, sir.
Or you could stop and go, what
did you just yell, you warlock?
How did you know
the incantation that
opens up the pink and
perfect cave of mystery?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: But none of
these are telling them
that it's inappropriate.
GREG PROOPS: Hey,
James Bond, where'd you
get that savoir faire?
Men really feel the
need to let women
know that they think
they're hot or whatever.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes I
think it's not even that.
I'm in gym clothes.
GREG PROOPS: Oh, it doesn't
matter what women are wearing.
AUDIENCE: I don't even feel
like I'm looking this way.
And I just want to go to
work and be left alone.
GREG PROOPS: Well, I say
this onstage all the time.
And I swear to God, men in
the audience are like, what?
Half the audiences are
still at the point of, well,
I don't know what you mean, man.
Yeah, you fucking do.
And I always say to men, never
mind your sister, your mother,
your wife, your girlfriend,
your aunt, your grandmother--
all the women in
your life that you
should relate to that you love.
How about you?
Ever thought of yourself
in another person's place?
Empathy?
If you were a woman and you knew
this was happening constantly?
And now we have
incontrovertible evidence
that it is happening
all the time,
that maybe you might
reconsider yelling out?
And then maybe if
you're with other guys
that yell out and act like that,
maybe you might remonstrate
with them and say,
hey dude, you're
being a major douche wad?
Yeah, it doesn't matter
what women look like.
And it doesn't matter
what they're wearing.
They get the same thing.
You could be wearing
sweatpants and a-- That's
my joke with the laundry.
You're wearing sweatpants and
you have a do-rag on your head
because you haven't
washed your hair.
And that's when someone yells
out [NONSENSE SOUNDS] Believe
me, women get it all the time.
Well, I hope those
suggestions helped you at all.
AUDIENCE: I loved them, yeah.
GREG PROOPS: The other
thing you could do
is go (IMITATING DEAF PERSON)
I didn't hear what you said.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
I'm not ready.
I'm not ready for that.
GREG PROOPS:
(IMITATING DEAF PERSON)
Please repeat what you said.
I didn't hear it.
(IN REGULAR VOICE)
Oh, look what I found.
It's for you.
Or, is your voice so loud
because your dick is so small?
That's the one.
I think we're about done here.
We've gone to 2:07.
And I think we're
going to do books.
Is that what we're doing now?
Signing books?
MALE SPEAKER: Yep.
GREG PROOPS: Well, if
anyone wants to buy a book,
I thank you.
In any case, I thank you all
very much for coming out.
I think for spending the
time, except for the girl
who split halfway through.
And I thank you for coming
out and watching me.
I really do appreciate
your attention.
And I'm sure this
is being broadcast
all over the infinite universe.
And everyone's going
to be like, I didn't
realize he was that profane.
But in any case, if you
want to buy the book,
I'll be over there sitting.
And I'm happy to take
a picture with you
and sign it for you
and all that jazz.
And thank you very
much for your time.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]